[Music]
so one of my recent columns in
Scientific American is what was called
sky gods for skeptics or as I used to
call it a aliens for atheists basically
the idea is that aliens and
extraterrestrials in our imagination we
haven't found any yet so they're all in
our imagination are often portrayed as
these almost godlike deities you know
they're super advanced technologically
scientifically morally you know they've
somehow overcome war and poverty and
these sorts of things and so I got to
thinking about this it's it's very
similar to the religious impulse which
is that we're not alone there is
something out there more powerful than
us who knows about us and cares about us
who loves us you know that's the kind of
deep religious impulse we're not alone
and that's the same impulse people get
when they think about extraterrestrials
even so and the crux of my article in
Scientific American was there was a new
paper published that showed that people
that have this longing you know so
there's variation in this some people
have more of that longing than others
those that have that longing but are not
religious are more likely to believe
extraterrestrials are out there in other
words if you have the religious beliefs
you know God Jesus mom and whatever is
your religion is you don't really need
the alien so you're satisfied with that
but if you don't have that then you're
more likely to go for the
extra-terrestrial hypothesis as a viable
one in the sense that it makes me feel
good because let's face it religions
have no more evidence for God then
scientists have for extraterrestrials
it's all imagination and speculation
based on reason and logic and arguments
but we still have any empirical evidence
so short of that I find it interesting
that that that it becomes sort of an
emotional appeal or you know a deep
desire for us to feel like there's
somebody else out there and I'm not
alone and let's face it that does feel
good and there's nothing wrong with that
but but we should always suspend
judgment until we actually have evidence
for this we may be the only ones in the
cosmos that are sentient beings and if
so all the more reason we should care
for our world and each other because
that would mean this is it
[Music]
you